the pecos is special because it gives
you a wonderful slice of the diversity
of northern New Mexico's countryside I
like just how many faces it can show you
the subtleties of the desert landscape
there's so much life in this semi arid
environment it's just a beautiful place
right now we're going down streamed some
nice-looking scenery some deep canyons
and place where I've been catching some
good fish recently
a little couple nice river crossings we
have to look forward to I've been
fly-fishing since I was 6 years old but
it took me until I was eight to catch my
first fish on a fly by myself the green
obviously signifies where its deepest
the trout like to settle in there
because they don't have to work as hard
to fight the current there's little
white foam bubbles that shows you where
the current supply of food is and the
fish can just sit there and at their
leisure pick off aquatic insects
drifting by if I were a trout I'd want
to live here
I like people when they're fishing
because they're a lot nicer especially
if they're catching lots of fish
for the most part it's rainbow trout and
brown trout the beautiful stream born
rainbow I've seen fish up to maybe 26 27
inches in here the biggest reason to
fish the Pecos is that it's simply an
absolutely gorgeous place to fish I've
fished all around the world and the
southern Rockies are just a wonderful
place to fish
you